Music
So our first groundwork exercise is going to be to move the shoulder over from the ground.
So some key points are that the horse does not step forward into your space.
Imagine you have a little bubble around yourself and they can't step forward.
So you see me there correcting him every time he tries to push his nose, his body, his energy
into my space.
So it's important also to know what type of horse you're dealing with.
This is a semi-reactive three-year-old gelding.
So he likes to play with things.
He likes rewards.
So find out what your horse likes and give them that as a reward.
So if they like to have a little walk around so that they can go forward from this exercise,
that's a great reward.
If they want to be pet on the forehead like this horse, that's a great reward.
If they want a treat, carry treats in your pocket.
Just be mindful that they're not abusing any of their rewards.
Now the purpose of this exercise is for them to not step forward into your bubble, your
energy bubble.
So you see me not moving my feet, he cannot walk on top of me at all.
And when he does it well, then he gets a reward.
The other thing is normally we would like the foot to step behind the other forefoot.
But in this case, when you're brand new to this exercise, it doesn't matter if it steps
forward or behind, except a sideward step no matter how it looks.
Just like that, exactly.
And then forward pet.
Now you see me squatting there, that is to encourage the horse's head to come down.
Something that horses have a hard time with is putting their head down without walking
forward.
So make sure you teach them that in some way before you start this exercise.
Okay?
And you see me constantly correcting him from stepping into me, and that's very important.
Some other horses we're going to want to step away from you in which you have to draw them
in with the pet or in with the rein.
You can do this without a saddle on, just a halter.
I like using a bridle so I have both sides of the bit.
And later on they can be in a halter or a rope halter to make sure that they understand
the exercise.
Good, as simple as that, just moving the shoulder over one step at a time.
You notice immediately when he starts to move, then I snap the whip back and release him
completely from the exercise.
And spend time in reward.
If they really enjoy having a walk or if they really enjoy having a pet, spend time there.
Talk to them, give them what they need to feel like they've done a good job, especially
with these young horses or horses just that are wanting to please, they need to know that
they've done the exercise correctly.
It's important for you as students to see the entire process of how we get to the point
of him actually accomplishing the task with consistency.
So that's why I've shown you all these videos.
So now by the end of the little session here, he's not only more responsible for not running
over top of me, so I'm being a little more strict about him not running on top of me,
but also he is much more accustomed to the exercise.
He has a good understanding of what's expected of him.
And there you go, perfect.
Good boy.
So the squatting down is really working for this horse to bring his head down, which is
important for his spine to come into a neutral position and relax.
And also a very obvious reward, perfect.
One step is all you need.
There you have it, your first exercise.